feel like audiences are opening up now
to hearing about gay experience like you
know that's the thing i used to go
through is this too gay is that not too
gay and i'm like
what am i talking about i love strides
and i take it in the ass obviously what
i'm gonna talk about is gonna be gay if
they don't like it whatever
you know but i mean i def i have lots of
different material and maybe it's
some people interpret it as gay some
don't but there's just so few gay comics
i think people are now like
when i go on a show like the audience
perks up a little bit because they're
sort of like oh it's great it's changing
it up it's a different perspective like
i like different perspective
yeah i think so much in like comedy is
trying to find that unique spin like
if everybody's going to talk about this
one thing it's like what is the most
unique version of it
you said the most eye-opening thing to
me last week when you were like it seems
like
the that people at first are very
interested in gay comics oh
this is this is industry-wise yeah can i
talk about that or not please
it seems that at first they're very
interested in gay comics you get a bunch
of heat but then when the moment
comes to actually put some money behind
right like give them a special or give
them this
gay ceiling yeah yeah it is the gay
ceiling
and um yeah it's like you see it
initially hit
because it's unique it's different right
and it's so fun and it also
there's like points for diversity it's
like a mascot-ism a little bit
there's a little bit of mascotism but
then when it's time to like hey hey
let's do an hour i mean you did netflix
you did all these things i did at 15 on
netflix which was great
but since i've been trying to sell an
hour like four different versions of an
hour and the response is always the same
because they're like oh my god will
people be it's almost like their bigoted
view on people they're like whoa well
guys
comedy central is a male channel it's
like well guys want to watch a gay dude
you have to prove it to them so that
they don't lose their jobs right
and um i mean i was in the position and
i guess
this is why i was giving you advice like
obviously not a gay comic but like they
didn't want to [ __ ] with me at all
right and i had to prove it and i you
know the numbers back it up
right and we went out and we did some
pretty cool work and then
the numbers backed it up and that's what
i say that you should do because i think
you got it merrill and i don't mean that
you know just to like
play kate i really do think you've got
it you know me i don't really shout out
a lot of
people that i think are i don't do it
for networking i don't care to network
right
if i if i want you on a podcast or if i
think that you're funny i'm gonna
try to you know share that with as many
people as possible but but you're great
man
and um i think you should just [ __ ]
bet on yourself dude i am i'm putting my
clips up on my
great and it's working right yeah i've
got it's like shocking i was like oh i
guess i should stop at the nudes and put
up something
and you know what you should do i think
it's a balance i think that you should
just have the because
i see you put like a cover or a
thumbnail of you and like a sexy pose
and then you're doing the
up i think you just put you at the mic
and close up on your face dude
yeah because what's gonna happen is like
it's gonna happen is like
there's gonna be a certain amount of
people that aren't gonna watch the video
maybe because they see like some guy
who's looking super gay right
but i bet you if it just pops up on
their explorer and they're naturally
going into it and then you start talking
and you're like
oh yeah jafar is totally gay like
they're like wait a minute
and all of a sudden they go this guy's
[ __ ] hilarious
right and now you don't have that
barrier of entry which is a guy's
fragile ego of looking at a dude
who is buff with his shirt off right you
know
you're like tricking like tricking them
into liking mateo
not liking hot gay guy right because
that's way harder for a straight dude
yeah to go i like hot gay guys i'm sorry
i don't know my friend that's the
monster nick
but uh but you understand what i'm
saying right yeah yeah yeah so
i i wish you best of luck and i hope
everybody who listens just goes
first it's been so long i love you but i
love our guy code girl code
i know i know i know this is very fun to
be here with y'all
and i'm glad people got to hear you i
know you were like oh i'm not being
funny anymore i'm glad people got to see
this part of you too because
if you want to know matteo's challenger
just look at his ig it's all there but
to hear
him actually say like things that were
more personal and maybe a little
vulnerable i thought was awesome
yeah this podcast is not just like we
have a joke every 30 seconds like i want
to have some
you know serious conversation and then
like i think the funniest stuff comes
from that
right you know like get to that place
where it's very vulnerable
and we're gonna find some funny in it